-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden
was interviewed last night
by CNN anchor Jake Tapper
and not, as he was expecting,
Walter Cronkite.
"Ah, you must be
the new kid, huh?"
President Biden said
in a new interview
that he doesn't think that
Russian president Vladimir Putin
will actually use
nuclear weapons,
though I don't think
it was a good idea to add
[Imitating chicken clucking]
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview,
President Biden said
he doesn't expect the U.S.
economy to enter a recession
but added that if there is one,
it will be "very slight."
You can watch the entire clip
in a GOP campaign ad in 2024.
[ Laughter ]
Buckingham Palace
announced yesterday
that King Charles's coronation
will take place next year
and said that the event will be
"rooted in long-standing
traditions and pageantry."
You know, the things that drove
his son and daughter-in-law
completely out of the country.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate recently held its
12th-annual bipartisan luncheon,
which featured more than
560 pounds of barbecue
and I'm guessing
at least 10 paramedics.
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the Netflix series "Monster:
The Jeffrey Dahmer Story"
has been viewed
more than 700 million hours
since its release.
So get ready for NBC's
newest series, "Chicago Dahmer."
[ Laughter ]
That's right -- The
Jeffrey Dahmer Netflix series
has been viewed
more than 700 million hours.
I guess because it was
slightly less horrifying
than "The Great British
Baking Show's" Mexican Week.
[ Laughter ]
"This is too much for me.
Should we go back to Dahmer?"
And finally, a winner
was declared yesterday
for the annual
Fat Bear Week contest.
Said the winner, "Wait, I
thought it was just Bear Week."
[ Laughter ]
You guys, guess what that was.
That was the monologue.
Let's move on.
We got a great show
for you tonight.